В Ізраїлі вже третій день продовжуються бойові дії.
Армія країни повідомила про повне відновлення свого контролю в населених пунктах,
які зазнали нападу з боку бойовиків палестинського радикального руху ХАМАС.
У суботу, 7 жовтня, ізраїльтяни прокинулися від звуків сирен та ракетних обстрілів із Сектору Гази.
Бойовики ХАМАСу проникли на територію країни у день релігійного свята.
Сигнали тривоги звучали у багатьох містах, включаючи Тель-Авів та Єрусалимі.
Соцмережами ширилися відео з загиблими і жорстким поводженням з заручниками.
Я б сказав, що це дуже страшно, насправді це була найстрашніша ніч у моєму житті.
Я був з деякими туристами з Європи, ми були в будівлі, ховаючись під сходами, коли влучила ракета, тому це дуже важко.
Відповідь Ізраїлю була миттєвою: армія розпочала контртерористичну операцію "Залізні мечі" в палестинському Секторі Гази.
Ми у стані війни. Не на операції, не на обході, а на війні.
Ізраїльські військові мобілізували тисячі резервістів.
Ми робимо те, що потрібно. Ми переможемо. Потроху. Все буде добре.
У нас є підрозділи, які знають, як діяти в подібних ситуаціях, вони ходять від дверей до дверей, від дому до дому,
стежать за тим, щоб на ізраїльській землі не залишилося жодного терориста,
і борються з людьми, які підняли зброю проти нас.
Загалом, за оцінками ізраїльської армії, з початку бойових дій убито вже сотні бойовиків,
зокрема близько 500 - у Секторі Гази.
Прем'єр-міністр Ізраїлю Біньямін Нетаньяху попередив, що країна "входить у довгу та важку війну",
а уряд збирається припинити постачання електроенергії, палива та товарів у Сектор Гази.
Все, що використовує ХАМАС - ми перетворимо на руїни.
Я говорю мирним жителям Гази: йдіть звідти негайно.
Ми працюватимемо скрізь і з усією нашою міццю.
Ізраїльські сили у ніч на понеділок, 9 жовтня, завдали ударів по понад 500 цілях у Секторі Гази,
повідомили військові країни. Імовірно, вже в найближчі дві доби Ізраїль розпочне наземну операцію в Секторі Гази.
За даними ООН, більше 123 тисяч з понад двохмільйонного населення Гази
були змушені покинути свої домівки з початку масованого нападу на Ізраїль бойовиків ХАМАСу.
Цивільному населенню складно залишити Сектор Гази, бо це є досить густонаселена територія.
Ми говоримо про 2 мільйони двісті тисяч людей.
Газа не поділена на райони: тут ХАМАС, а тут ні.
Складно відокремити публічні місця. Наприклад, це відділ поліції або база ХАМАСу.
Навіть деякі офіси в цивільних будівлях можуть бути офісами організацій, які афілійовані з ХАМАСом.
Станом на ранок 9 жовтня відомо про понад 700 загиблих в Ізраїлі та близько 2400 потерпілих.
У Газі кажуть про 436 загиблих і близько 2300 поранених палестинців.
Палестинські бойовики заявили, що утримують у заручниках понад 130 людей.
Глава "Ісламського джихаду" Зіяд аль-Нахала повідомив,
що заручники повернуться додому лише після звільнення палестинських ув'язнених з ізраїльських в'язниць.
Окрім запеклих сутичок на півдні країни, Ізраїлю довелося також тримати оборону на півночі.
Це почалося після того, як з ліванської території у бік Ізраїлю було випущено кілька ракет та мінометних снарядів.
"Хезболла" та палестинські угруповання - потужні воєнізовані формування, які підтримує Іран.
Давно говорять про об'єднання в рамках так званої осі опору.
Проте, за словами джерел близьких до угруповання, "Хезболла" хотіла надіслати палестинцям сигнал солідарності,
а ізраїльтянам - чіткий, але обмежений сигнал готовності.
Європейські лідери та США рішуче засудили атаку ХАМАСу
та висловили повну солідарність з Ізраїлем і його право захищатися.
Ці дії є варварськими. Вони обурливі, і їх нічим, абсолютно нічим не можна виправдати.
Ізраїль має право захищатися від цих варварських атак, захищати своїх громадян і переслідувати нападників.
Глава Європейської комісії Урсула фон дер Ляйєн заявила,
що напад "є тероризмом у його найогиднішій формі".
Засудив напад на Ізраїль і президент США, назвавши дії ХАМАСу "безпрецедентним терористичним нападом".
Чи не відверне війна в Ізраїлі увагу західних партнерів від війни в Україні
та як спалах насильства на Близькому Сході вплине на подальшу підтримку України у війні проти Росії -
наразі невідомо.
Тим часом в Україні рішуче засудили напад бойовиків на Ізраїль і висловили підтримку.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський порівняв напад палестинського радикального руху ХАМАС на Ізраїль
із вторгненням Росії в Україну, зокрема він провів паралелі зі звірствами військ РФ у Бучі.
Зеленський також розкритикував позицію Ірану у зв'язку з війною в Україні і Ізраїлі.
Іран не може казати, що не має нічого спільного з тим, що відбувається в Україні, якщо продає "шахеди" Росії.
Іран не може казати, що не має нічого спільного з тим, що відбувається в Ізраїлі,
якщо його офіційні особи заявляють про підтримку того, що відбувається в Ізраїлі.
Тим часом іранська делегація в ООН заперечує причетність Тегерана до планування або здійснення атаки ХАМАСу на Ізраїль.
Єдина арабська країна регіону, яка доєдналася до засудження бойовиків ХАМАСу - Об'єднані Арабські Емірати.
Позиція ОАЕ помітно відрізняється від коментарів більшості інших арабських країн регіону,
які поклали відповідальність на Ізраїль.